all right people I believe we are alive
that's right doing a little Google
hangout while we build out our studio
and I am joined by the bleached blonde
British super villain is it okay i
bleached I'm a natural blonde I have you
know that I'm I just had it no I just
had it done again it's great yes in case
you don't know who it is it is at Euro
on Twitter he doesn't have a glue check
but don't hold that against him it's my
lawyer Napoli's ladies and gentlemen
hello I've come in my heterosexual
outfit for you today I've come as
straight as possible because you know
you're you're like the gay one out of
the two of us I often think you know
like I'm the one is kind of like Oh gay
marriage is crap and what's going on and
you're the one with like the husband and
you know you much camper than I am so I
thought I thought I just gonna meet you
where you live today so I come back I
come I don't tread on me
rainbow Gadsden flag thank you for
upping your gay to match my gayness I
don't think I don't before I'm that's
never happened for another gay person
before how are you darling I'm good I'm
good
first off I just want to tell you I'm
seeing those rainbow don't tread on me
flags all I live in West Hollywood over
here which is pretty much the gay
capital of the world I'm seeing those
posters all over the place no joke yes
well it's Pauline a result actually it's
almost entirely fueled of course by
conservatives because it's the guys from
flag obviously it is people are putting
them up all over the place just
interesting a consequence of of a
horrible thing that happened people are
rediscovering I think a sense of sort of
gate defiance and and they're
rediscovering you know what it might
mean to to protect yourself and to take
your own but you know you're projecting
into your own hands I think the left is
realizing we're gonna gauge this
intercourse the conversation I think the
left is realizing that all of this sort
of peaceful peace and love [ __ ] from
dumbest Fox celebrities and all of the
you know
gun control hysteria from liberals is
only making them less safe and the
saying that every time one of my friends
on the Left says we have to be evil with
love and hope and happiness is that
that's not how you beat it I'm
suggesting to you and this may be a
radical proposition that mullahs in Iran
and indeed hate teachers in the north of
Orlando might confront you know hashtag
strong together you know hashtag proud
to be with a chuckle and then continue
their plans to kill us yes it's so
controversial with you it never sucks
all right so let's pause first I mean I
just think I speak common sense but hmm
yeah all right so we're going to get
into a lot of stuff but I want to just
remind people first off I want to thank
you for doing this because as you know
we went independent last week and we're
I did for you know more editorial
oversight you can finally unleash the
inner beast that has been waited to come
out you've called me a cultural
librarian but I during my popular
libertarian phase right now right so so
everyone's been crushing it on on
patreon and we've done really well on
there but what we're going to do is we
want we want to get to our next here
which is the 30k tier and Milo is going
to help out so anyone that donates over
25 to 5 or more on patreon for this hour
while we're doing this you're gonna get
a live shout out by me and Milo and
maybe I can convince Milo to say
something mean about you I I know you're
busy today and distracting I'm fine it's
fine I'll try I'm actually in Alaska um
I'm here visiting my friend Ben Oh some
people from the interview will know
pizza party van um is he he's he's the
head of the troll army for Trump uh and
yeah so up in Alaska did you know that
there is a town about 20 minutes drive
from me who's mayor is a cat did you
think yeah they it cat it's a cat with
no tail that lives in a bar and it is
the mayor of the town and Sarah Palin
when she was mayor of Wasilla used to
serve with this cat unlike the mayor's
Council is amazing this is the lives
done I'm guessing that that town
probably functions better than 90% of
the guys address it does yes
the cleanest best run chief its nicest
place to live in honor mile radius of
call centers sort of your theory because
you've told me this about Trump before
that for all the bravado and all the
craziness the way you think Trump would
actually govern would be that he
wouldn't do that much so I guess having
a cat in charge that's just licking
itself you know fiddling around with its
tail and looking for mice that way
that's your type of government
well Belgium didn't have a government
for a very long time and City I mean
obviously you know Belgium does have
some problems not least with homegrown
jihadism but aside from that which is
you know a bigger cultural problem um
the people of Belgium noticed precisely
no difference whatsoever to their daily
lives when they simply didn't have a
government I went on quite a while I
mean not like three-week kind of like
three-week crisis it was months possibly
even a year or something the country
just didn't have a government and guess
what everything was great oh the world
didn't collapse you know figure it he
did not cave in I have something of the
same feeling about Trump presidency
which is that I think he's gonna build a
wall which is good and fixed trade which
is good and there's gonna get so locked
up with Congress and you know whatever
and all the things that he wants to do
that you won't be able to do he's gonna
be kind of like a blustery Coolidge
Coolidge being the best president in US
history because he did so little um
Calvin Coolidge uh you know he's just
gonna be kind of like a blustery College
and that's awesome and you know I I'm
well anyway everyone knows oh yeah so
your things let's just do a little bit
of trumping then I want to get into some
of the more interesting stuff with
moment cuz we've talked Trump before but
your thing basically with Trump is that
people really aren't voting on what he's
saying as much as this social justice
stuff all of the the fear that the left
has created over saying certain words
and not dealing with Islamism property
and not having an honest conversation
about immigration these things that
basically that that concept that fear
that people are walking around and of
their own thoughts
that's why that's really what's driving
you to Trump right it's not about policy
per se because definitely what's driving
me to Trump although I do want him to go
the wall
and I do want him to fix some of the
trade things I think there's a slice of
the American population which has not
been served well by successive
governments and I think they deserve a
crack of the whip arm it's probably a
bad choice of expression given but but
you know more more broader I'm a culture
person I care because ultimately I think
the realm of ideas and discussion and
debate in the public square journalism
you know whatever is is one of the most
important bits of civic society and
that's the bit I live in and a bit I
care about the most and Lib it you live
it than you care about the most and the
general effect of Donald Trump is to
open up a listen see this is happened
already this is already happening
the general affects Donald Trump is to
shine a light on who the authoritarian
nannies are who or who the people I want
to control your life whether they're on
the right or the left and open up the
space for ordinary people to express
opinions which had become for no good
reason
professionally dangerous and so and
socially social socially disadvantageous
so you know that thing for me is the
individual things that Trump says you
know he's no more or less inconsistent
any other politician I don't suppose
he's certainly a lot less corrupt than
most politicians he is a lot more honest
than most politicians the extent to
which he speaks um you know with too
much bluntness and turned some people
off uh I think the overall effect of
Donald Trump is going to be to smash
Rendell hold of political correctness on
American public life and he is supported
in that effort by the cultural
libertarian movement and free speech
activists like us and I think it's a
good thing and he you know the people
who have come out most strongly against
Trump are all of the worst people in the
world the people who hate him the most
are the people who are tearing America
apart the people who hate him the most
other people who are going to destroy
the United States of America if they are
allowed to run rampant and to continue
to to hold a poacher to have purchasing
and hold sway over the media at the
entertain industry and academia if these
people are allowed to run those three
great cultural institutions of American
public life they will destroy the
country and the people who hate him the
most of the people who are the
problem and that to me speaks volumes
and for me is it's a you know vote for
Trump even if it's just a sort of
cultural protest vote and I say even if
actually that's not a terrible reason to
vote for a president at all you know
America is founded on ideals not on you
know GDP you know Merck was founded on
ideals if you're voting for ideals and
that ideal is freedom you know probably
the most fundamental and significant
ideal on which that the you know your
great country the best country in the
world was founded it's not a terrible
basis to vote for president really not
at all and this election being for
culturally rather than economically
culturally rather than the basis of
foreign policy this election would be a
good time to send a message not just to
the you know boring octogenarian
half-wits of the Republican
establishment but also to the social
justice warriors on the left and their
enablers you know the people who turn a
blind eye at the excesses of black lives
matter the people who allow the worst
kind of mizzen jurist lesbionic hateful
feminism to for all women and all
feminists you know who do not call out
bad feminism when they see it and have
in fact allowed bad feminism to
completely take over the entire movement
those people deserve a kick in the teeth
and if Trump can give it to them I think
you should vote them all right so there
is the opening statement of my lowly
innopolis there you go I think I think
that was sort of that's your that's your
ballpark stuff that's what sort of made
you the the super villain of the
internet so we got that out of the way
but let's talk let's talk about what's
going I know you can't believe that I
even said that you can't believe um but
let's go enough with Trump let's talk
about the Orlando thing because I think
it is hit something huge something that
we look we are both gay so this attack
any attack would have been personal
because I'm an American so any attack on
our soil would have been personal but
this attack particularly was personal
because for us we're gay we know what
it's like to go to a gay club go to a
gay bar where it's one of the only this
is in a case where I'll use the word
safe space in a not joking way that it a
gay bar is a safer space for gay people
to be okay with I know I'm off the
phrase safe space all the time it's not
safer ideas it meaning it's safe for you
to
who you are there um and we know that an
Islamist who called 911 to Isis murdered
these 50 people there's a chance that
this guy was gay and his own self hatred
which could have only been instilled
with him through a backwards religion of
ackwards ideology forced him to do this
and the left of course completely
dropped the ball and I'm fighting to
make my people relevant and instead they
hand these issues to guys on the right
and this is where this is where me and
you look a lot of what you just said I
think is a little a little over the top
with that Trump's gonna save the world
in that way but I think this issue is
somewhere where we see things completely
I died you know what amazes me is the
cowardice of the left so I went down to
Orlando the police lied and said they
couldn't they couldn't guarantee my
safety
so um they canceled my college talk then
I set up a press conference for the
following day and the University got
spooked and they cancelled that so I end
up having a press conference at ground
zero like down where this should have
happened um just gave most of the speech
that I was going to give her the college
and took questions from the press it was
big as I 100 200 people whatever it was
I don't even know you know took our own
private security down all the rest of it
and I took him I took Gavin McInnes
who many of your viewers will know he
was commentating for the rebel media
Anthony Kim you network whatever and we
having taken own private security with
like snipers on the roof and guys around
behind us and you know the New York
Times and Deutsche Welle and and and
Washington Post watching kissed after
you know after after Gavin McInnes is
sort of little feel he said you know
what [ __ ] you as long as America um and
you know we kissed and it was like you
know a kind of a kind of a dangerous
thing to do a few days afterwards you
know I've been telling the police have
been telling me don't go out don't give
the speech you know you're gonna get
yourself into trouble you're in danger
we can't protect you so we did that and
then and then the response from the left
like two days later when everybody had
sort of heard about it but pretending
they didn't know about it and if I Oreo
they're just making it all about them
they're just like right wing
attention-seekers then this is kind of
like you know two men kissing thing
where people are just like sitting in
their living rooms and going darling I
love you isn't as terrible with those
wrong together with so brave you know
I'm just like who's really
the risks here right like getting out on
to this is and this is the problem not
just with this one on both sides
actually people who are just lazy and
don't really care and want to express
themselves in the most um lazy and easy
way possible either with the kind of old
peace love and understanding or the
virtue signaling of all we must stop gun
culture well you know what the world
isn't as you want it to be you can't
just evaporate like you can't just poof
all the guns in America away there are
like millions of guns in circulation and
the only only thing you can do is arm
people so they can protect themselves
literally all you can do rage I saw war
outrage over you in some instances from
people on the left more outraged that
you're instigating eight and you're just
this provocateur who whatever and look
you it you admit you are a provocateur
that's what you're doing but of course
when I went down to underscore the
hypocrisy yeah I went that's I went down
there to underscore the hypocrisy of the
left just say you know what you have
screwed up so badly that this this
minority these gay people that you
thought you owned for three decades or
whatever or more um you just lost it all
in a day by acting wrongly after this
you know the whole massed ranks of like
the gay establishment cancer celebrities
the media all immediately came out this
piece of an understanding [ __ ] and
anti NRA anti-gun stuff and ordinary gay
people are at home being like hang on a
minute no you don't serve my interests
here you are not speaking for me you are
pushing your own politics
you know this has got nothing to do with
gay people and it's got everything to do
with your politics and gay people have
been suspecting this for quite some time
in the last election in the UK fifty
percent of gay men said they were going
to vote conservative and the Guardian
are left-leaning newspaper reported this
with horror they can't understand how
great gay people could be so ungrateful
well I'll tell you how we're so
ungrateful we're ungrateful because the
left has abandoned us we are ungrateful
because the people who claim to have gay
people's interests are pushing their own
far left crazy ideologies instead of
advocating things that would make gay
people happier safer and richer when was
the line basically they're putting the
oppression Olympics in effect and
they're saying that Islam holds a higher
slot than gays right is that
yeah with that the problem with that is
Muslims want to kill everyone else on
the list you know you put them at the
top of the oppression pyramid you know
the top of the victim on hierarchy they
want to kill everyone else on that list
Black's [ __ ] gays you name it and
then get in the oh you know I want every
gay charity in America to be shut down
of as a result of their response to this
when was the last time you heard a gay
charity genuinely doing anything to make
gay people safer I've heard a lot from
them in the last two years about
transgender pronouns but when was the
last time you heard about them from them
about HIV how much money and attention
they spending relatively speaking how
many column inches are they getting on
those two issues just out of interest
because what I see is them pursuing far
left issue of the moment horseshit at
the expense of gay people who are
experiencing and actually everybody's
experiencing skyrocketing HIV infection
rates where are the gay charities
addressing the fact that 52 percent of
black American gay men will beat will
test positive for HIV in their lifetimes
I've never heard about it why because
they're so [ __ ] up and confused they
don't they don't even know if it's
racist to address it you know like can
we even say that black people have AIDS
at a high race it doesn't that just
perpetuates a [ __ ] you Frankie
they've grown their own crazy logic
dealing with race and religion and all
that has trapped them into this [ __ ]
so a great example of I have invested
interest in this I don't want black
Americans to have AIDS because I'll get
it
oh you know I want these charities to
actually do stuff that's going to help
gay people like for instance be
realistic and instead of parrot Hillary
Clinton's talking points about the NRA
and about all evil southern gun culture
maybe do what gay people are doing and
in their hundreds of thousands and look
at the world as it really is and say
there are these people out there who
want to kill us Muslims don't like gays
very much not Islamists not terrorists
Muslims they don't like gays very much
and this is not me being like some crazy
right-wing lunatic 100 percent of
British Muslims in a Gallup poll a
couple years ago so the homosexuality
was unacceptable they did not approve as
a lifestyle choice 52% of them or maybe
51%
to get within a percent of that believe
that it should be made illegal this is
not Islamism or terrorism this is Islam
this is Muslims and if you find that
uncomfortable tough [ __ ]
where are the gay charities so telling
gay people how to protect themselves
where the gay charities saying you know
what maybe we don't want like guns in
nightclubs because guns around people
drinking is not such a good idea
but here are all the places you can go
to like learn how to use a firearm to
protect yourself and your boyfriend and
your loved ones whatever they don't and
the simple answer to that the simple
answer to that of course is that if
those numbers were reflected in in the
Christian population the left would be
going bonkers but let's pause for a
second because I know people want to
hear from you so you got a garan say hi
Darren quick Sam yeah what do you out of
town what do I have to say it about them
to love you I just say you love Darren I
love Darren you love Trenton don't you
love Trenton I do love trenton I've
always been a fan of Trenton you love
the skeptic fence show am i right the
skeptic fence show they sound like
atheists but I'm gonna say for you Dave
just for you that I love them that's
right
you love mayor Stubbs he's the cat up in
Alaska he just donated 25 yes it is Maya
Stubbs yes uh you love Tedder don't you
love tanner
I do love tanner tanner tanner Tata can
Oh Tanner do you know it's called Stubbs
cuz it doesn't have a tail oh is that
right major so when we uh quick-quick
radio reset what we're doing here I'm
here with my lawyer innopolis and he is
he's helping me out with our patreon
push oh and by the way I don't even say
this at the beginning but we have
someone a private donor who is matching
everything that you guys donate while
I'm on with Milo will match up to $5,000
so basically any number that can give
while we're doing this double so it's
patreon.com slash the Reuben report all
right so let's jump back in so I want to
talk to you about the virtru signaling
because I really do love this phrase and
it's something that I see so much again
on the left I'm trying to get these
people to be better but this is great
serve American public life now this
woman Sally Kohn who works for CNN after
the Orlando thing was lonely I just
pressed by the name Sally Cohen I just
threw my [ __ ] everywhere
she was tweeting up a storm about how
all the religions are bad and they're
all equally bad
are extremists in all of them and just
everything's equal equal equal and I
tweeted at her and I said which one can
you at least say which one would be
worse for an outspoken Jewish lesbian
because that's what she is
he's a Jewish lesbian on CNN who gives
her opinions for the reason please left
on CNN let me guess our politics no but
but of course she didn't respond even
though it got hundreds if not thousands
of retweets and it's like you call them
on their [ __ ] and they just
disappeared but it's abject or [ __ ] and
it needs to be fought she is and she
knows I was called her this now because
she sent me an email saying thanks for
the shout out in your Lambo press
conference mylanta press conference by
the way every [ __ ] media meet major
media organization was there none of
them reported on it why because it was
too [ __ ] awkward because they knew
they'd get back to the registers notice
like you know and and the Washington
Post guy said that he told somebody else
one of my team that he didn't know
worked for me because I've got like
every every time I doing these talks I
just like you know for people in the
audience to go and like ask around and
whatever and one of my one of my guys
was just wandering up his remember the
public talking to the press there and
the Washington Post guy and the New York
Times guy both said the same thing both
the person the New York Times and The
Washington Post but of course they were
there right and multiple people there
they were there and they said yeah my
editor just won't go for this but it
doesn't matter because you know what
you're doing with your new independent
show you know crowdfunded which is
amazing um and people should support you
I think because I you know this is this
is the one of the one of the only things
I watch with any regularity so you know
you should um you should definitely
support him but the other like when you
get humble and that doesn't that feel
good good in your heart feel good when
you do that I don't know if it was
humility I was just pretending to be
nice cuz you get an hour of it uni
internet um no I mean you know like Dave
knows I love him I do love him um what
was I saying yeah so they won't just
they'll just new their editors wouldn't
run it but you know it doesn't matter
because what you're doing and the kind
of numbers you get and by now I think
probably like I mean millions of people
have seen my press conference now the
copy on my youtube alone which is one of
five platforms that are just mine and
there were loads of other people that
the players whatever stream
that one's that like 900,000 millions of
people saw that without a shredder
broadcast coverage so you know the
journalists that are enabling a lot of
this stuff and I'm wondering off topic
slightly but the jealous a lot of this
stuff um
increasingly ceased to matter and I
wrote a column today with my customary
modesty it was titled my fame and update
oh I thought I thought you did oh good
you take you promised you'd permit you
look sorry if there's anything that you
could put in a Google chart I love my I
love I love my Google Trends graphs I
love them um no I I absolutely adore my
Google Trends graphs mainly because they
show me as being more famous than
everybody I know but um I'm starting to
overtake people I used to look up to
like venture Europe yeah you know what I
mean sure about yeah I really um and who
else
Piers Morgan I'm more interesting than
Piers Morgan Jeb Bush uh Glenn Beck I've
now overtaken I mean these are like big
these are you know and almost every fox
news host so you look at Hannity
O'Reilly and megyn kelly this isn't in
the Oscar she writes with this the other
day these are people with daily shows
that go to like millions of people on
Fox more people searching for me I mean
like that's the thing I mean I watch
these shows sometimes on CNN and Fox at
MSNBC and nobody you see what these
people who have major TV time right they
have they have major major millions of
dollars behind them nobody retweets them
nobody engaged and nobody cares what
they say but they go to parties with the
politicians and these people just all
are interesting I should say Sean
Hannity anything is great and I love
Sean Hannity I don't say about what I
get about him I think he's been great
the last couple of months but um they
people just don't find them that
interesting but they find you
interesting and I find me interesting um
I'm obviously like really rich so I
don't need your money but des hommes
could with some help because dave is
going independent and dave is you know
breaking free of the shackles of his
corporate overlords and he's gonna run
the show himself which i think is very
brave and very exciting I was
conservatives have all the money you
guys always have all the money I look
like work work had no money I've seen
the conservative what's going on the
money I'm trying to be a good guy on the
Left there's not a lot of money in that
but my fans have shown up and
awesome so that's very cool no I mean
every single venture capital investment
in left-leaning media companies has been
to left-leaning media companies in the
last I don't know 20 years that's simply
not true if you're not getting
investment you don't like you know you
don't have the right kind of business
venture capital or whatever all of the
money is on the left in media of course
that they done regressive left I would
argue and that sort of real a true
liberal 3-speed but there is no true
liberal free speech left left I mean
there aren't any of you and there are no
publications like that so of course
anything that goes to a left-leaning
publication is going to a crazy
left-leaning publication because they
are now the same thing there is no
difference you know if you want to
support like a you know if you're
interested in like libertarian
center-right sensible fact-based thing
on the right you could go to like reason
you can go like a bunch of places there
isn't anything on the left anymore
they're all mental and readers are
starting to notice and there's another
graph in the piece that I published
today my fame and update available at
Breitbart news going to provide a
constant reminder that I'm getting
better now I always forget to anyway um
there's another graph there that shows
like slate and the Atlantic and salon or
they're trafficking room and me starting
to overtake them all in searches right
that's very significant so how much do
you fear that some of this because yeah
a lot of the tech money is what I would
say coming from the regressive left and
we know these crazy speech things on
Twitter you got banned again the other
day
can you describing everyone wants to
know Lee when you get these vans for
hour out of nowhere or you what happened
after Orlando is you were I think you
were getting death threats and they
danced to ban you when that happens for
an hour what is that like like you just
suddenly can't get in and then how do
you get back what actually is oh well I
don't know because I mean it has
happened because my staff tell me has
happened because I've never been
actually on the computer when it's
happened but um on the phone it just
doesn't let you tweet and just as you've
been suspended but it's still less you
go to the mentions column and like read
every one that's mentioning you so I can
see did they tell you why you got
suspended oh no oh no no no no sometimes
they don't even send you an email you
just get a little thing saying be
suspended learn more you have to go to
this long page of [ __ ] and then find
a link that's buried in the bottom of
nowhere and then click that there's a
forum too
Wow and you think you've done it and
then there's a little email they send
you like a little while later not
immediately which says all you've got in
small writing reply to this so we know
you've got your who so we don't write
email for you otherwise you know won't
do anything and if you miss that you
know it goes with the ether if you do
reply to that eventually sometimes
perhaps something will happen but
obviously Twitter I mean I'm pretty
convinced there's like a person at
Twitter paid full time to deal with the
Milan office problem they they really
don't like me very much
cause a lot of a lot of headaches for
them and my you know I get unsuspended
faster than I've ever seen anyone get
suspended in the history of Twitter
because they're like oh Sh it's happen
again we can't deal the press so and I
think pulling a little bit of an Obi one
with you like if you strike me down I'll
become more powerful than you can
possibly imagine because every time you
come back you have more followers so
it's like their least out of their own
ineptitude I mean like keep suspending
me guys please it's working great you
put me on the front cover a Drudge
thanks buddy
I mean Milo you're holding a lighter are
you gonna burn the whole place down now
that's what it's all about really but no
no no no no I just lost my lighter I was
gonna have a cigarette with you um but I
don't know why we're giving you
cigarettes I was gonna you can come if
you want yeah come with me come with me
I'm gonna smoke up yeah I'm gonna come
with you while you're doing that tell
Cameron how much you love them you love
Cameron don't you I love a you know
camera I've always been attracted to
Cameron's I've always sexually attracted
to Cameron's almost every camera I've
ever met I thought was pretty behind you
you got a you got a tie-dye play you got
a Trump thing you got a Confederate this
is not this is not my house but um but
but there are some there are some
interesting and thoroughly sound flags
around my lapel shinigami how much you
love him or her Janene go me I love you
so much I love you enough to tell you
change your name yeah and what about
Stacey what do you think about Stacey
Stacey um you seem fine yeah she's gonna
want more than that she donate money I
love Stacey about nesting everything we
don't describe everything you donate
while I'm 25 and above gets doubled up
to five thousand bucks so please jump it
have transcended the limitations of your
agenda
and become a sensible god-fearing
serious person with excellent taste and
donates to Dave Rubin and for that I can
only congratulate you look II know
you're Glasgow Rogan I wanted real what
what's the weather like in Alaska right
now um it's nice it's sunny can you see
me yes yeah no it's nice I'm just up
seeing friends and having some fun I did
a video up here about brexit that's exam
you talked about so I watched your video
and you were decked out as soon eautiful
asking mountains behind you and you
talked about and a lot of people have
asked me about it and you know my
general feeling I've said I'm not an
expert on Brighton but my general
feeling is that every nation has the
right to protect its borders that as it
see fit and I tend to think with
everything going on there right now that
I would be for you you laid out a pretty
damning case why you are for it yeah but
mine was based on one very simple very
straightforward and very specific issue
and it wasn't an issue to do with GDP or
even national sovereignty which
conservatives are normally consider
normally normally upset by because I
don't care as much about that well of
course I do care about it as the the
Muslim problem now I've been I started
being outspoken about this aisle
congratulating myself there because I
think people are but I sort of I sort of
came clean about just how strong my
views were on this subject on your show
first and you you know you should if you
want to make a distinction here between
like Islamists and Islam I said no and
in press appearances since it in columns
I've sort of expand explained why that
is the case and shared studies with
people to show the social attitudes of
Muslims not just in the East but in the
West to mum a Project Lead every one sec
since we've done this a couple times and
you don't like that distinction that I
consistently make so I think it's a good
little spot for us do you at the end of
the day I personally if there were
Muslim people I would say this about
Christians would use her anywhere else
if there were people that didn't want
gay marriage or didn't or didn't approve
of gay
bah-bah-bah as long as they weren't
harming gay people I wouldn't be happy
with their political choices but I would
be I would be okay with their right to
be here
you know you'd me of that I've worked
out why the left gets confused on this
I'm work I've worked out the specific
kind of idiocy among her many different
kinds of idiocy that Sally Kohn has
fallen victim to here it's the fact that
the left has eroded the distinction
between speech and action over the last
thirty years it has begun to call words
violent on campus I just I figured it
out yesterday on campus they call words
violent they need safe spaces from
opinions so of course they think
Christians are just as bad as Muslims
because even though the extent to an
extent of a Christians homophobia is
going to be saying do you know what I'd
probably rather not bake a cake for you
and I'm the extent of a Muslims
homophobia is I'm going to kill a 50 of
you the left doesn't really see the
difference between words and action it
has forgotten that there is a big
[ __ ] difference a difference
enshrined in law a difference that most
ordinary people most people the brain
understand instinctively there is a
difference do you mean saying I don't
like you very much
any punching you in the face one of them
is legal and perfectly reasonable the
other is not and when you forget that
there is a difference between words and
action and when you are you know some
cosseted rich white coastal blogger [ __ ]
and you think that you know my opinions
about whatever it is you know black
lives matter constitute violence well of
course you're going to start to lose
perspective when actual acts of violence
occur so this is what's happening on the
Left this is the problem this is why
they can't wrap their heads around the
difference and they can't get
perspective between Christians who I'll
give you an example like the response
from Muslims just the response from
Christians to me in the last two weeks
I've my store which sells like tickets
point to my tour and t-shirts this morn
of the rest of it has received I think
today I mean I don't even know each
other in one day they received a hundred
death threats and threats of violence
from Muslims in a mixture of English and
Arabic now we don't make a big song and
dance about it I mean I mention it of
course but I'm gonna victimhood tall
like the left does because it's beneath
me but basically that you know that
myself were terrified they were
threatening to blow up the warehouse all
this kind of [ __ ] right now
that's the response
from Muslims to not liking my opinions
right the response from Christians when
I went down to when I went down to
Orlando the response from Christians who
and Anika at you know um this would this
was a group of Christian volunteers who
have previously objected to gay marriage
their response was may we pray for you
and there wasn't like trying to pray the
gay away they were like thank you for
coming down what you're doing is brave
like God loves you and you know we
admire you and you know what you're
doing is really important and you know
go out there and speak the truth as you
see it you know that was the response
from you know from Christians but won't
play then to the Christians now I'm
still on our board because I got you I
got you there is a huge difference
between shooting people in the [ __ ]
cake which I'm so sick of hearing about
the cake but they're but a lot of the
conservative Christian community has
done a lot to fight gay marriage right
so glad have it now we got it so it's a
great it's a net win and they've been
but a red I don't particularly like gay
marriage that's just a set of opinions
that's something for us to discuss you
might not like those politics but that's
a cause for discussion debate and and
you know political fighting and and you
know whoever wins wins whoever wins the
pot the popular vote whoever could
persuade the public you know use the
course of how that society is governed
and organized right if you win the
people over you get what you want and
you do that through persuasion and the
left has done that with gay marriage and
I've kind of come to the view that you
know you can't really stop people who
love each other from declaring that and
you know in official capacity and they
should have the right to do X Y Zed and
you know yeah fine like the state should
probably recognize that I just wish they
wouldn't do it but whatever you know you
can't stop people but um that's and I
don't understand why people like Sally
con don't see this that is is it not
somewhat different from hate preachers
saying as the guy who was in Orlando
four weeks ago in that hate mosque in
Sanford in the north of Orlando four
weeks ago giving a lecture saying how we
you know about how we fix the
homosexuality problem this guy is on
record saying the compassionate thing to
do in Islam is to kill all gays right
and
then somebody who you know in Orlando
who went to these mosques you know who
declared himself Isis killed a load of
gays I mean we don't do this in
Christianity if we did it was a very
long time ago and there's nothing to be
gained quite big crochet there's nothing
to be gained by playing what about URI
with ancient normal ancients with
history
you know today what is happening today
who is causing the problem today how do
we protect the most vulnerable
minorities the most vulnerable people in
our society right and I don't happen to
think women are particularly vulnerable
anymore I think they're probably
probably the most privileged group you
know like white milk last women always
make these complaints for the most
privileged group in the history of
civilization but I think there are not
as physically strong as men all the rest
of it if you know and they deserve not
to be brainwashed into wearing [ __ ]
her jobs in my view but again this is a
matter of opinion when you start to
enforce your political or social
opinions through violence that's when
there's a problem that is the moment you
you know that the whole world should be
saying you are the problem and we're
going to do what it takes to protect
ourselves from you but the left doesn't
do that the left instead starts making
excuses for them saying oh well the West
created this problem
look visit infantilizes muslims to the
status of children who lack free will it
infantilizes them to you know to being
the mindless automaton products of
american foreign policy that's [ __ ]
insane well Douglas Murray who I know
you know who's been on my show who I
absolutely love who also is gay so I
think that's what one of the things
that's interesting happening about gays
being outspoken right now you know gays
are always thought of his outspoken like
we like drag shows which I never write
like haven't been thirty years but now
it's like were we were the ones on the
front lines like I really feel that I
was at the gay pride parade here in West
Hollywood that that Sunday after Orlando
and there were truckloads of cops and it
what it look like army uh you know
trucks like it was nuts because the army
provided this now because it's become
dangerous to be gay again why Islam like
it hasn't become danger physically
dangerous to be gay in America because
of Evangelicals because of Mormons
because of Zoroastrian
it's not the [ __ ] Buddhists you know
that have got police out protecting gay
pride marches it is Islam and that is
the case everywhere you look in Europe
where Islam as you know has had a huge
influx of kissing Germany's is in Sweden
Malmo now the rape capital of Europe you
know they attack women they attack gays
I'm gonna go to Sweden in a couple of
weeks and lead the parade in Sweden
through a Muslim ghetto because actually
nobody knows this yet so this is
breaking news uh last year you'll
remember that the Swedish authorities
Swedish government you know these are
far left social justice lunatics who are
trying to create you know it's a
progressive paradise in Sweden well I'll
tell you what a progressive paradise
looks like a Brooke country where all
the women get raped
now it's heard of email from Sweden IAT
no sound in dodgy there is one of the
only people who will talk about the
immigration situation right so a year
ago Swedish authorities told a gay March
off for being too unnecessarily
provocative for marching through a
Muslim area now to my mind the point of
gay pride was always to be brave and
defiant in the face of hateful social
conservatism right as as I thought I
thought that was it ah that's what
they're doing that's what they're doing
and so I'm gonna go and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be there in Sweden in a couple of
weeks March through this this this
heavily you know heavy Muslim area to
remind people I hope it will remind
people in Europe at least what the
problem is today it is not Buddhists or
Christians or Zoroastrians or Confucians
or even much-maligned atheists um none
of this none of these people are taking
to the streets with assault rifles to
kill gays wait a minute are you telling
me that there's no atheist in the name
of not believing in something that you
can't prove is killing gay people we're
not gonna get into the religion argument
because I don't wanna embarrass you by
beating you in another debate but um
pretty bear what do you think about
resting you love that Justin guy don't
you
Justin is amazing just my first boy from
school Justin it may be the sparrow
you definitely love Harold I do love
Harold and Daniel oh my god Daniel it's
good good Christian or maybe a Jewish
name either is fine we like
let's not forget about Craig Craig yes
Craig is good Craig is a British name
crow Clausen British Craig's maybe it's
uh maybe is somebody from my home
country yeah um alright so what we're
doing here patreon.com/scishow and
report everything up to five thousand
dollars is being matched right now so in
effect you guys are going to be double
to keep the show going and build it out
and all that stuff and Milo is playing
along and giving me the Trump thing how
does this become a Trump thing oh it was
Ben who I'm staying with do you know
everyone says I have everyone says I
have stumpy fingers like Trump do you
think I have stumpy fingers I don't
think I've stumped you think is that
normal fingers right those look there's
a little Trumpy and a little stubby a
little Trump scope it's a perfectly
normal hand it's a completely normal
hand oh I wish I could just push that in
your face right now that would be
alright alright it's a perfectly you
know what I asked you to do this before
I don't know wait the rest of your days
oh yeah you got any booze over there
what if we'll do some shots tutorial no
no no I'm not drinking I'm on a new
workout regime I'm not drinking
that's your Europe you're a binge and go
guy cuz I've been with you oh you're
drink like crazy and then you just won't
eat for six months well I mean I eat but
I like protein shakes and whatever you
know so yeah no I'm Avenger for sure so
I just I'm just getting into entering
into my hoffmans look at this look I
might as well have AIDS the number of
[ __ ] pills my trainer makes me take a
look at this
this is like a day just like full of you
can't see it it's just right Ray
Kurzweil singularity live for everything
well I'm already gonna live forever I'm
gonna live forever in the minds of the
people
hopefully by dying young and tragically
so people fight in my name for you know
for generations but um right my guides
are telling me that a lot of people are
donating on PayPal right now so if you
want to get a shout out you got to do it
on patreon so it's Rueben report com
it's patreon.com slash rubin report
everything's being doubled up fine let's
not tell you off forgive me money before
stop it you people who are giving money
on PayPal you suck
oh you're good people - we love you we
love you you took over 25 bucks you're
getting the shoutout from 25 bucks and
above on patreon you're getting a shout
out from PayPal as well so we can be
nice to PayPal people because I love
them even if you don't date yeah
alright ok they're over here's what
they're telling me there are over 4,000
people watching this right now so if
everyone gave a buck that we got it
match like that okay then I come and
join one of your streams you get numbers
almost approaching my numbers you see
there we go nice every time I see you
the first I said maril how are you it's
nice to see what's going on the numbers
that you've drawn to me and then I would
ask you only am I wrong you're a numbers
guy you deliver numbers what can I say
I'm sorry I'm so mean no look um you see
they think that the the reason we make
such a good team is that we are greater
than the sum of our parts you know
combined we have like you know
reasonable persuasive kind relatable
nice guy
and we have Dave Rubin um no no you were
very very very good team so we produce
excellent results and good product
um yes you're actually what quite a good
private guy agree well what time
actually your your appearance on my
podcast is one of the fan favorites so
far I I reluctantly confess this might
be because it's the only conversation
we've ever had in which I let you speak
it's so pleasant I just gotta set it up
by the way you know people want to
listen to that which they can get it on
iTunes and I think you put it on YouTube
also you know that was about two weeks
before the Orlando thing and in the
middle of it around 40 minutes in you
asked me what do I think the biggest
issue with the regressive left is and
and I said Islam and the gate I mean
that's what I said because I do this as
you've been talking about this we've
been talking about this yeah you put an
ideology that is directly against one of
your protected classes above that
protected class and that is so
fundamentally dangerous and we see a
repeated but you know what let's let's
go boys from some of the politics cuz we
did we ask people to give questions and
I got like 400,000 questions that people
want to ask you so one of the big ones
is who's my leg on Apple is dating these
days what's going on in the Roman
take away the Annapolis I don't talk
about that actually you'll notice that
you'll notice I never put anything about
my real actual private life on the
Internet
um mainly because I don't want to get
fact uh you know even people who just go
out with me like you know I have like
black friends I dropped my talks the
black eyes protesters a black lives
matter protesters like try to assault
them at the police have to stop them so
as somebody actually dating me is in
real trouble so I make a point because I
you know I live very publicly and I sort
of do everything in public and I kind of
exist for other people's educate
entertainment education and and
edification and I'll enjoy that and I
love that and I have a lovely
relationship with with with you know
social whatever but uh I have to keep a
little sliver of life for me and I also
have two other people that I care about
are safe and are happy and are protected
a bit from the chaos that surrounds me
at all times um totally fair and
actually just for the record because you
know for all these wing nuts that could
save my little too racist know that not
only do you actually you really like
black gangs like you really do but when
I went to the UCLA thing with you just a
couple weeks ago every you know I didn't
know what to expect right so if you see
the Trump rallies on TV it always seems
like there's this redneck element to it
involve on it I don't even like saying
that like because it sounds dismissive
and I don't I don't want to be
dismissive up the middle of the country
which is where plenty of good people
live and it's what New York and LA
always dismisses real America yeah but
what everyone that I met after the rally
people are coming up to me saying they
were conservative they were liberal but
there were Asians there were blacks
there were people in wheelchairs there
were everybody there were try to I meant
to trans girls I mean everybody was
there and a lot of people think the only
reason they're defending you isn't even
that they like what you're saying as
much as they just want to defend your
right to say it
and that's what I'm all about so that's
the beautiful thing well yeah I mean it
was nice that you got to see that and
nice that you came to one of the talks
I'm going to try and invite all of my
friends to sort of guest appear a
dangerous [ __ ] or and you and I'm sure
we'll do more of them for the end of the
year um for a racist sexist misogynistic
homophobic transphobic
no monster I don't have have a diverse
crowd at my event seem like it's a
pretty good mix now yeah sure there's
like a good contingent of like frat boys
and all the rest of it and and so what
[ __ ] you ah but you know that they're
great uh and you know but there's a lot
of women a lot of women who come up to
me afterwards and they're like thank you
for this because these people do not
represent me and I don't want you to
think all women like this and I know
what women are like this is the tiny
fringe of people who like control
everything I know that not all women are
like this um don't worry sweetheart and
a bit bit lots of them and and you know
a lot of Asians as well because I'm
socially Asians by which I mean you I
never know what people mean by Asian
America but I mean like Chinese people
and uh mainly Chinese and because
there's Muslim in American in big
American universities and social justice
has turned on Asians because now with
the SATs you know if you're Asian
um they penalize you because male like
Asians have a culture working hard and
they study really well and so they
perform really well and so to give you
know to give like black and Hispanic
kids more of a chance to drop out of
university which is what always happens
when they get a permit of action places
uh to give a to you know to give back
and I and Hispanic kids a chance to
waste a college place they penalize
Asians um you know it's not even white
people who are the primary victims of
the SAT gerrymandering in the u.s. it's
it's Asians and I've started to notice
like a big like it's it's like a small
little cluster of them and then but it's
starting to grow in my talks and every
talk I do now I noticed a larger and
larger proportion of Asian students um
because they've you know you might if
you're not particularly educated or
well-versed on this stuff imagine that
they're just another minority the left
has kind of got under its wing but
actually they don't like them at all why
because they're successful and positive
and enthusiastic and hardworking and
glamorous and guess what the left hates
all those things because yeah alright
alright let's let's just plow through a
whole bunch of it I got literally like
500 questions here uh so Melissa do you
support the legalization of weed I don't
think we've ever talked about weed
before I'm obviously a hundred percent
for legalization what would be worry on
the weak I guess maybe that's why you
always seem so dunderheaded are you have
enough stones
it's coffee decent Milo decent right no
I'm more of an up as person I guess uh
no I I'm off all that I'm all about
family okay but oh you're okay with the
legalization right on I'll give you an
answer to that I'm on I'll tell you what
I'm I'm on fish oil and vitamin D
multivitamins and creatine and some
other stuff that I don't even know I
just put it in my mouth uh I think the
war on drugs has been a colossal waste
of money
and a terrible disaster I don't like
weed because I think it makes people
stupid but um I can't for the life of me
imagine why it's illegal um I think
that's a good enough answer right there
wait
say hi to vision storm what's going on
vision storm vision storm yes ain't your
name - no I'm just kidding I'm guessing
it's not your real name vision storm
what about necro dead you love necro
dead necro death dead dead Oh necro dev
yeah no we like you we like you necro
devs good name good name all right guys
we are double all the Patriots are being
doubled over 25 bucks everything's being
everything being double but over 25
bucks Milo's gonna give you shadow while
we're on here okay let's see what else
you I'll give you 500 dollars you can
have that from me as a little present so
you can eat some better
Milo you're not police now see that
that's what you know I'm like I'm
embarrassed by all these people donating
I feel like I've been I've been I've
been publicly shamed into giving you
money to look absolutely work all right
tell me what about you I've got to
declare an interest but [ __ ] it I'm not
giving you a piece of the company sorry
buddy uh I want two percent and no less
yeah here's a good one because this is
something that you mention when we did
our talk in UCLA you said that um that
black people are still owed something in
America which I think really pisses off
a lot of your base in a whale um but you
acknowledge I think it is actually no so
yeah go ahead uh no I think what I what
I meant by that is they're still you
know people talk about the legacy of
slavery there is obviously still one and
you know you do get to talk about racism
if you're a black person right I'm not
going to pretend that there is ZERO
races in the United States I don't think
it's the problem is made out to be I
don't think that spoiled brat
black lives
Atta protesters in expensive private
universities you know with wealthy
families whinging about you know
microaggressions have very much to
complain about but yeah there are some
lingering things and they deserve a
better answer and even where there's not
um even where it's not a slavery thing
because I know some people like isn't
that just like sins of the fathers and
don't you hate that all the rest of it
and I totally get that argument and that
you know that that point that that to me
is only a small sliver of it the main
reason why people Oh blacks an apology
um the main reason why people Oh blacks
and Paula G is how badly Democrats have
run black cities
and black people have some
responsibility for this because they
keep voting them in but you know whether
it's the Clintons or whether it is the
invariably
Democrat mayor of Baltimore or Detroit
or whatever it is right who have run
these cities into the ground with
terrible policies who have done nothing
to help blacks you know men are rare a
rare occasion you'll get something like
Giuliani who saves thousands of black
lives by policing properly where there
is an apology that white people have to
make to blacks it is Democrats you have
to apologize to blacks for how badly
they have run their cities and how
grotesquely they have they have worsened
the racial divide in this country by
treating black people as children by not
policing the communities properly by not
holding them to the same standards by
not you know not giving black America
the tools it needs to raise itself up
and out of poverty and gang culture and
crime and it is you're robbing people of
the of the you know the tools they need
and robbing them of aspiration of the
American Dream telling them that they're
there all of their problems are someone
else's fault telling them that you know
if anything is wrong in their lives you
know if their brother got shot or
they're too poor or they can't find a
job that it is a white guys fault
is the worst kind of you know what is
the kind of you know it's a kind of it's
kind of sort of colonial racism really
it's just sort of keeping keeping people
quiet and keeping them down by telling
the lies and that's not how I would fix
black America I would fix black America
by giving them better schools and
encouraging them
go to Harvard rather than breeding
grievance culture and victimhood which
is what the left does why well the left
ones to engorge the size of the state as
much as possible it wants the largest
possible federal government and you know
what it wants all those black voters
locked in well actually it's one and
it's caught them because was it 88
percent of blacks gonna vote for Hillary
you 88 percent of black people voting
for Hillary are [ __ ] dumb well
because the issue really is because then
they owe you nothing if you have a
voting bloc that you know is going to
vote for you no matter what you actually
owe them nothing so it would actually
you can promise them the world and
deliver nothing which is what Obama did
Obama you know the racial relations in
America have got worse not better under
Obama why because he promised to be this
post-racial healer and then did nothing
and in fact tacitly you know allow the
situation to get way worse by well
there's that most most of the time Obama
didn't act when he should have and he
acted when he shouldn't have right um
you know is made unhelpful and
counterproductive statements where he
didn't need to speak at all and where it
really would have been nice if he'd
intervened like with black lives matter
for instance saying sit down shut up you
idiotic petulant children funded by some
you know rich Jewish billionaire lose
like lunatic shut the [ __ ] up I'm going
to fix this by giving blacks better
schools better access to education and
the workplace and all the rest of it and
you know improving the quality of
housing all this Custer you can do any
of those things and neither will Hillary
Clinton alright moving on we got a lot
here people we got a lot of furious
things I wanted some more like fun stuff
but a lot of seriously so this I think
this is a really good and it's a serious
time in America you know yeah I think
this one and a couple people ask
something to this effect they've heard
what you said about Muslims and what
they want to say is well that doesn't
you know for that for the average person
out there so if you're some kid some
Muslim fifteen-year-old that's in
Detroit who just wants to play video
games and he's like any other kid that
doesn't prescribe to these believes or
subscribe to these beliefs how do we how
do we win that kid hears you say those
things that he might go wait a minute
but mine that's you're talking about my
mom or my dad or my grandpa's like how
do we reach out to that kid in an
effective way because that's where I
always make that distinction and I know
I get what your senses on that
distinction but it's obvious that there
are there are kids
out there and some adults who don't
subscribe to this stuff how do we reach
out to them without demonizing the whole
population or they're not really Muslims
if they don't believe that stuff you
know they're kind of cultural Muslims in
the sense that lots of us are cultural
Christians like you know we might go to
church a couple of times a year but we
don't really like do it and believe it
all right if you're if you're a Muslim
and you're just like a normal
assimilated American because you know
your parents who your grandparents were
rich enough to be able to fly here um
you're not you know I mean like do any
of these people that you're talking
about pray five times a day you know do
they read NMR so they like you know
giving there's a cart are they you know
are these people are you know devout you
know like know the extent to which you
are not bigoted and not prejudiced on
you know women and gays is inversely
proportional to your you know your your
seriousness about your faith all [ __ ]
obviously you know some sort of one the
the Muslim community in a way to do what
Jews have done which is pretty much most
Jews are not religious in any way but
you know light some candles on Hanukkah
or whatever else is it yeah I mean well
this is the issue is a bit more complex
with Islam because if that religion
makes claims for itself the others don't
you know final perfect unalterable Word
of God and you know that you know the
Hadees and the center and the Koran
together constitute you know the last
you're gonna get and that causes some
problems as some structural problems
that Islam hasn't been able to adapt
itself as fluidly or indeed at all
really like Christianity has to
capitalism Christianity is an apt a
Shinto modern democratic capitalist
capitalistic liberal society has been
phenomenally good has been remarkably
effective at adapting itself to the
civilizations in which it lives and
staying you know staying current whilst
protecting the core tenets of his faith
but there are all sorts of problem
unique problems with Islam that prevent
is long so not the non-believers that
the other religions don't say but are
let's move away from Widgeon I'm gonna
read off like ten names you I just want
one adjective per name okay you ready
I hate these games okay Angus Angus um
beefy this I know they defer you know
that Angus steaks or something I don't
know dad what Dan um
I don't think anyone's had a reaction to
the name dance oh man the upset but for
our purposes down is wonderful yeah is
wonderful Scott Scott is a good name I
always imagined Scott's as being like
snowboarders with those oakley
sunglasses you know that's like Scott
that is that's Nicolas Nicolas very good
name I had a very good friend at college
Nicolas afraid of our Catholic good Lana
Matt I'm really taxi it's like you could
talk about anything forever but if I
asked you for one word to describe a
name it's like okay I think of the
problem the problem is asking me to be
concise all right so I'm gonna tell Matt
and Dylan and Erin and Martin that
they're all great they're all wonderful
and and I don't have anything
interesting to say apart from Dylan of
course you love you you love Dylan um
well listen we're questioning here we're
almost at 21 K let's get to 21 K and
then I will let I will let my logo so if
you guys get us the 21k I'm gonna let my
little go play in Alaska and thumbs to
shoot keeping me from an ar-15 so that's
it up there you get your gun and you
shoot some balloons and you're
expressing your freedom is Palin up
there she is we were down to we were
down to meet up but she couldn't do it
cause she had family stuff Father's Day
weekend so maybe next time um but uh
yeah she's she just animal so I'm in
Anchorage um which is a little bit north
from there nothing what's it like when
you go back to London now because you've
sort of you've become it away like a
more of a cultural force or whatever in
America and you probably are at home
right yeah um I may have one in England
knows who I am I think but they don't
particularly like you very much in
England because I'm too blunt and too
brash and too outspoken and - you will
find this difficult to believe but uh
Brits find me a little self
congratulatory um you know they face I
can't believe it I have word that no
they don't like that so much because the
British way is to be humble and modest
and self-effacing and if you can believe
this I am regularly charged with a lack
of humility in England so yeah I know
I know they don't like me very much
there because I actually say what I
think and that's not what British people
are supposed to do so British people who
you know sort of um have a have a bad
habit of speaking their minds tend to
end up in America I I want to see what
your house is like in England that
picture a Downton Abbey thing there's a
drawing-room generally I believe a lot
of people downstairs that's what I'm
saying yeah um I have a nice house I'm
building a new house I'm currently my
builder has quoted me I've said this
before and it's not actually a joke I'm
really thinking about doing it
my builders quoted me an extra 50,000
pounds it's like 70 80 thousand us to
build an actual glass ceiling
um in between like the third and the
fourth floor so no like no women above
you know the third floor it's like a
real glass ceiling you know actually and
it was funny um oh you see what you've
done to me you talk so fast with so many
bizarre words with you British people
and you said a glass ceiling I didn't
even put it all together yeah no no I'm
I'm currently deciding whether I put
actual glass ceiling in the house Mary I
know it's I my God knows my house is
gonna be nice it's gonna be a four off
four and a half thousand square feet um
on four floors which is not huge for
America but it's quite big for London uh
and it's gonna have like I'm gonna
decorate it in sort of successively more
elaborate layers so the ground floor is
going to be like clean like marble and
glass and the next floor up is kind of
like cozy country cottage and the next
floor up is like Grand Ostia French kind
of like 13th aren t small kind of big
ceilings like dark wood big furniture
and then the top floor my bedroom is
going to be like Versailles you know
like big gilt mirrors and the library in
the dressing room and everything seeme
fantastic people want to know the real
difference between Dave Rubin and Malaya
doubtless the real difference is that
all I want is to not have all IKEA
furniture you're you're building
Versailles in your bedroom I mean the
difference between the two of us I
worked very hard and I've always worked
very hard I've worked hard for nearly 10
years and I'm enjoying the fruits of my
I know what you were to say I know you
are but look I'm not lying I am on ikea
couch and there's my lane yes I don't I
can't look at it I can't visit it I
can't look just too horrible well listen
I'm gonna I'm gonna let you go but I'm
first off I want to thank everybody that
jumped on patreon and it's Rubin report
Dom says donate a patron kansai true but
afford and we're doing something great
here and and listen you know for me of
you it's just the beginning whatever it
is that the two of us are doing and
whether I agree with you as I keep
telling people whether a super you about
on everything it's a moot point
I gotta defend someone's right to say
some [ __ ] and that you really did
everything you you are falling in line
one by one with everything I've ever
said when I came on your show first time
and you were like when I came on the
second time you had basically moved 75%
of the way towards me and you are
falling in line with everything because
you know I'm basically right about
everything but are you just gonna take a
little bit more persuading you know
whether you ever vote Trump I don't know
but um but everything else you're coming
over I know you're coming over I'm gonna
get you on everything well um 500 bucks
my friend
well I might have that William whatever
this peculiar affectionate affectionate
bromance is brewing between us for the
edification of the American public I'm
enjoying it and I hope that people do
support your show because I love it and
your show has been very good to me uh
you know the lots of people saw me first
on your show for which I'm very grateful
because when I wasn't such a big name as
I am now
you know that my the biggest thing I did
was was your show first time around so
um so I'm grateful to you and and people
should support you because you have
great guests and many more than future
actual Maya Annapolis you know how to
end the livestream you are a common
that's it alright thanks everybody
Milo enjoy the rest of Alaska thank
sewing go play with your freedom or
whatever it is you people do gonna go
shoot something some watch talk soon